hey Brian McCann i'm nicholas kristof
and I'm answering your question what
keeps you motivated I think you know
because I tend to bounce around Sudan
Congo Cambodian brothels writing about
these things people always try to think
that they must be incredibly depressing
and the truth is that when you go to
these places you see the worst of
humanity and at times that is upsetting
but side by side with it inevitably you
see the best of humanity and you see
tremendous progress being made side by
side with some really desperate things
and that is what I find inspiring I
remember on one visit to eastern Congo
the most lethal more since world war two
and you know I saw kids starving I
talked to women who had been brutally
gang-raped I saw some really terrible
things but I also saw this incredible
polish nun who was out there in the
middle of nowhere feeding these orphans
and providing education to some kids and
single-handedly trying to stave off
these warlords and i love it early
inspired by the human capacity to do
good and to make a difference and i saw
her making a difference and that is what
keeps me motivated thank you